we interrupt this program to bring you
Courage the Cowardly Dog fandom as a pup
he was found by Muriel whales in the
middle of nowhere with her husband
Eustace Bagge yeah but creepy stuff
happens in nowhere stupid dog
you made me look bad
we're gonna shake me a sliding rear pad
and welcome to I don't know both is it
fire and fire by running out of battery
that's okay guys with me again everyone
loved her in the night Deb everyone
loves your daily you down anywhere look
at my sweat oh yeah look at my fat you
read you read it in the title you
probably know I told ready know what
what did you say program or something
you want Alice okay you want to breathe
in my I don't know where to begin
I guess what is it your shout bye oh my
god
thank you Bruce for one witness we did
it we frickin dad act yeah
barrels what's your problem oh we reach
1 million went further down she's gone
crazy I can tell you bros enough
how much it means to me I never I
remember I made a thank you video when I
got a thousand subs so obviously that
was a big deal but getting a million of
Brits adds some pros that's that is
ridiculous
um I'm type of speechless I don't know I
remember like I said getting a thousand
subs and it's been ridiculous like we've
been a fastest growing channel on
YouTube and we still are and I I don't
get it I'm not gonna lie
but I I couldn't be happier about it and
I I feel like I'm merely and it's it's
just a number I mean yes it's an amazing
threshold but what I really care about
is all the support that I gathering from
you bros and that's really what's
important for me and that's what makes
this YouTube fun for me you know
but we are gonna we're not stopping just
because we reach 1 million let's go for
2 million shall we
funny cuz I'm always like a big dreamer
you know I was imagine I think everyone
does in secret maybe you think about oh
what if my youtube channel it goes
really big and stuff like that
I never ever expected 1 million that is
just ridiculous the things I do to
become so popular my I like I didn't
even know my personality was that big
funny for people you know I usually I
I'm not this crazy unless you know me
really well I don't act out crazy like
that to other people so it's it's funny
how I like for some reason I just let my
personality out on the Internet
and that just kind of became that thing
like it's it's so popular and I
I'm not like an attention-seeker I'm not
that kind of person
so but you know I'm still I couldn't be
happier to have so many of you bros that
watch my videos it really I really do
consider all of you as a friend almost
it's weird to say cuz I never met you
and I probably haven't talked to you
there but I don't know it's hard to
start to describe but I'm I care about
every single one of you and I couldn't
be happier about we reaching this far
all the success we've done with this
channel I owe it all to you bros I
always listen to your suggestions I was
follow your ideas and games to play and
stuff like that so it's something we
accomplished together and I am
overwhelmed by it I am I'm really really
it's amazing so thank you bros I want to
do a special video it's gonna be a
special video it's just making all these
videos it's really pushing my limit all
most like I'm putting a lot of time into
it and I feel like every time all the
time I put into it I get back from you
bros so it's really don't worry about it
but it's hard to find time to do extra
stuff like special video and stuff like
that so I hope you understand if it's
not gonna be up right away also I got a
pure box now here in Italy I got it
today so if you bros want to send me
stuff you can do it to eat this address
I'm gonna leave put it here or leave an
in description I'll probably make a
video where I update the things that day
you bros send me it's gonna be really
ridiculous the box is like this small
yeah I have no idea how your mail is
gonna fit there but I'm definitely
looking forward to your mail I hope
maybe I can do a live stream it's hard
to livestream because the internet here
suction like ah man come here I'm
tricking her head there's food Maya
what's up oh my god you're shocked 1
million I got two million [ __ ] yeah
yeah haters gonna hate haters gonna hate
hit me alright anyway again thanks for
all the support Bros and I'll keep
making this video right you got to do it
now we're a million out here there
should be a million people with your
face right now
alright you brothers ready for this epic
epic you don't want to miss this one
alright here we go
bro fair share Mon activate
you